j'arrive officiellement pour repartir en
congé maternité j'espère que d'un départ
temporaire mais qui a mes yeux rend
cette cérémonie d'accueil d'autant plus
symbolique puisque je suis accueillie
ici au moment où je m'apprête à
accueillir un nouvel être et cette
situation est peut-être assez inédite à
l'échelle de l'histoire juive puisque
bizarrement ces derniers siècles les
rabbins ont rarement pris des congés
maternité
ni les textes ni les hommes non de
visage unique c'est de cette idée que
j'aimerais être teintée mon rabbinat qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui être capable
d'accueillir les visages comme on lit un
texte sacré dans le sens reste toujours
à découvrir
finalement je me rends compte que je
continue d'enseigner beaucoup la même
chose ça me rappelle quand j'étais à
l'école rabini qui a un de mes
enseignants qui nous avait dit je crois
pour travailler notre humilité nous
avait dit que dans la vie en tant que
rabbin on a maximum un ou deux sermons à
donner en fait on finit toujours par
délivrer le même enseignement ce qui
éviterait des rabbins et bien évidemment
vrai des prêtres et des imams mais
peut-être de chacun d'entre nous dans
nos fonctions d'enseignement peut-être
qu'on a un discours à donner un
enseignement à apporter au monde voilà
un message à transmettre faut essayer de
trouver le bon mais moi j'ai
l'impression que finalement oui cette
question de la pluralité des langages
elle est très centrale dans dans mon
travail j'y pense souvent aussi
quand je fais face comme on y fait tous
face aujourd'hui à l'intolérance
religieuse au dogmatisme ou
fondamentalisme finalement le propre des
fondamentalistes c'est qu'ils veulent
chaud vous faire croire que le texte n'a
qu'un message et que ce message c'est
celui qui correspond à leur agenda
politique à eux